The moon is just sitting there, waiting for
us to go back.
It has resources, opportunities for science
and discovery, and Google's XPRIZE gives companies
cash to get up there.
Hey guys it's Trace with your Weekly DNews
Space Update -- and holy wah, Google XPRIZE.
If you're not familiar with the XPrize, it's
one of the ways Google is incentivizing other
companies to literally reach for the stars,
or in this case, the moon.
The search giant hopes to inspire "engineers
and entrepreneurs from around the world to
develop low-cost methods of robotic space
exploration."
The winner will be awarded $40 million dollars,
but there are other prizes as well.
The promise of the XPrize is what helped foster
SpaceShipOne; the first, manned private spacecraft
in 2004.
This week, Google announced the five finalists
who will compete for some of the OTHER prizes
along the way to that $40 million dollar GRAND
prize.
They're calling them "milestone prizes."
The finalists are from around the world, but
they're also from previously successful spacefaring
nations.
Two US companies, and one each from Japan,
Germany, and India.
From now until September, each company will
attempt to outdo the others in three areas...
ONE: land a robot on the moon successfully
-- that ALONE nets a cool million bucks.
TWO: drive the robot 500 meters on the lunar
surface -- for that you get $500-Kay.
and THREE: the robot must create two "'Mooncasts'
consisting of high-quality images and video
on the lunar surface."
This might seem like low-hanging fruit for
any lunar mission, but the point isn't to
break boundaries of exploration, but for non-governments
to be on a level playing field to compete!
Lowering the cost of space travel for everyone
in the long run.
It's important to note, the teams don't actually
have to PHYSICALLY COMPLETE the tasks to win
the prizes.
Yes, the winner of the GRAND prize has to
ACTUALLY COMPLETE these tasks, but the Milestone
Awards are about testing and analysis.
It's not a space race, it's a battle of ideas.
Competitors will demonstrate their hardware
and software to test which of them can produce
the most creative, simplest and affordable
solution.
From there, an international panel of expert
judges will determine the winners and award
the milestone prize.
It's not even necessary to attempt the GRAND
prize to win the Milestone prizes, and so
the companies are already competing on the
battlefield of ideas.
A company called 'Astrobotic' is hoping to
tap the wealthy public for additional support
-- promising the ability to ship a package
onboard their robot!
Just think, if scientists could afford it,
there could be new lunar experiments launched
in the next YEAR!
Or, maybe we could have a Coach bag dropped
onto the lunar surface...?
Maybe?
Have any lunar launch ideas?
We'd love to hear 'em so head down and type
my little space monkies!
Type!
Thanks for watching, we'll see you next Friday
with another Weekly DNews Space Update.